this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you everyone um I'm glad everybody
can come and participate I think we have
a as a chair of the state's own water
conservation committee we are looking at
a
massive Pro program ahead of us for
covering and and flaring off gas and we
are going to have to have a strong
educational program to get Farmers to
participate next slide please
um Greenhouse we raise uh all our
um newborn calves are raised in
greenhouses until they are uh weaned and
then the right side just slow shows cows
at the pump at their feed bunk seating
next slide
um southwest corner of our storage this
was covered by environmental Fabrics out
of South Carolina in 2012 it's a 60 mil
plastic you can see the water sitting on
top there's a concrete rib that floats
down the middle of it that holds holds
it down and water pumps on each end that
pump off all surface water next slide
it's um manure collection pits before
they're pumped up into the separators on
the left and the right is the uh
elevator that runs out the separated
solids into our coverall building where
we then use it to um
for all the different sources that's
good that's the coverall building
um you can see how it's steaming it will
get that hot 160 degrees roughly in 24
hours we want it to heat up like that
and then we use it to bed about 1200
freestalls two pack Burns
um that is freestyle there with the
solids in it is super comfortable better
that we went from sawdust and we'd use
sand and many other things over the
years but without a doubt the separated
salads are the most comfortable you can
use next slide
it's um that's a
opens a sealed container Hall where we
have our pit slopes from nine and a half
feet deep to 13 and a half feet deep our
pump out station is up in about the
middle of it we have this put in at the
very bottom of it in case we ever wanted
to pump it out dry we have never had to
do that there is no build up in it that
we can see yet on the right slide you
can see where the exhaust pipe where the
gas comes out of the cover and it's
headed toward the flare and it's all
just does it by uh its own pressure
uh next slide
on the left you see the welded seams
they have a special plastic welder that
welds all the seams together and on the
right is just the water that collects on
it and then we have next slide we have
pumps on it you can see the hose that
runs up there's one on each side with a
rib down the center and we just have
timers on them eight hour timers running
wherever you want it runs into the white
pipe there each pump has its own we run
it around to the other side of the barn
underground into a storage Pond which is
about a million gallons it is then
pumped underground six thousand feet to
a second Pond of six million gallons
which we Center pivot
um irrigate all that on growing crops we
collect all precipitation from the 12
acre Barn site our driveway runoff all
roof runoff all high and low silage
runoff off the bunker it's all collected
and stored and then irrigated in a
summer on growing crops next slide
um the cover or the flare that's the
connection of the pipe running into the
flare the flare is about a 14 foot tall
stainless steel tube it'll turn on
generally around July 1 when the Lagoon
gets hot enough it starts putting out
gas and it'll run at 1500 degrees
um right till about November and then
when the everything cools down it
produces a lot less gas and the flare
shuts off I think in the future
especially if they're going to go to
carbon credits we are going to have to
look at a way to collect all the gas at
all times even when it's putting out
very little in the winter so that
non-escapes right now during low flow
times it is not flared it just flows out
into the atmosphere and we are going to
have to have a mechanism in time to
collect all gas even and I would like to
be able to find a way to use the gas as
a heat Source you're talking uh three
foot wide approximate flame running the
1500 degrees for four to five months
there's a lot of energy loss we have not
determined yet how to do that but um we
are that is the goal of ours next slide
please
uh the nrcs conservation practice
standards next slide
and keep next one again
this is our back one up please great uh
that's our satellite Lagoon 6 000 feet
away uh we built that uh three years ago
uh it's got a plastic liner in the
bottom and then we are environmental
fabric just coming in I believe in April
and they're going to put a cover on that
and flare so it would be plastic on the
bottom plastic on top
the
benefits to the covers to for the Farms
one uh you're not getting any
precipitation in the manure so there's
no dilution of manure you have a higher
nutrient content in the manure because
you're keeping all that precipitation
out
uh in our main Lagoon that's roughly 1.2
million gallons a year that we don't not
have to haul as manure which is at least
a twelve thousand dollar a year savings
for us for not having to haul that
manure away because all that
precipitation is kept out and then we
have collected it all and use it as
irrigation this past year we irrigated
our
um next slide we irrigated approximately
150 acres and there you can see the 1500
Foot Center pivot that is connected to
the pond that is only 200 feet from the
stores are going where we pump all our
roof and driveway run off everything to
that site we ran eight ton to the acre
higher corn silage yield on that Acres
it was irrigated this year because we
were drier than a normal year and so it
at the rate
of return on that we would have paid for
that Center pivot in three years due to
this year's increase in yield doing we
did have a cost share Grant through
um this climate resilient farming
program to put the Six Million gallon
water pond in and the center pivot we
are now looking at putting in more
Center pivots due to the benefit we get
our location of our farm is below Lake
Ontario and up and above Lake Erie
enough that we don't get enough rain a
lot of Summers we are a drier area so if
we can irrigate it would be far better
on with just more profitable for us next
slide
uh keep going another one
and uh as chair of the
as chair of that I guess I'm at the end
of it anyway is chair of the state soil
and water conservations many I have been
on the committee for more than 15 years
and chair for a number now
I believe our job on on the state
committee is to help farmers meet
environmental needs and goals and
regulations on their farm and through
that working with the soil and water
committee we designed a new program a
few years ago the CRF to come climate
resilience farming program whereby
there is dramatic funding increase for
that program projected over the next few
years the goal is to cover
and flare every single storage in this
state it will be a massive undertaking
over a number of years but if we are
going to meet the 2030 goal of reducing
methane it is the best and easiest way
for farmers in this state to meet that
goal is by cover and flares on storages
ours puts out over 5 million cubic feet
of gas a year and so if you did that
Statewide it would be a massive uh
difference if you could flare all that
off and even greater if you could find a
way to use it which I think in time will
my time's up
that was fantastic Dale that was really
great thank you so much and also thank
you for your leadership in the state
both on the farm and for the state it's
really it's really appreciated
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu